[Music]
welcome back all right so this is the
part of the show where we had stand-up
comedy all week but we ran out of comics
so i decided why not read from steve
doocy's new book of recipes
who doesn't love a good recipe am i
right greg i can do it yeah so it's cool
yeah but we're going to devote a whole
segment to steve ducey's new book
i can do it i brought my microphone
already
i promise
steve ducey i will talk about his new
book of responses ladies and gentlemen
would you rather hear about gluten-free
spaghetti or listen to the one and only
cat tip
don't fall
i've been carrying this microphone all
week waiting for my shot
thank you
see how this goes
so no matter how bad your life is going
there's someone on the internet who has
it worse
and is being very open about that right
i have a few friends on facebook that
are always just blowing up my feed with
most depressing stuff in the world like
i guess it's just another night alone
watching tv by myself
in case somebody wants to call me but
they won't because no one ever dies
it's like yo that's because you've made
it very clear that you suck
no one is going to invite you to their
party if they're worried you are going
to stop violently at it
that's why on facebook you pretend
everything's going amazing make everyone
think things are going better than they
actually are it is like a padded bra for
your life
the internet can make you sad sometimes
too though because well there's a lot of
very hot people on there
i clip fake hair
into my actual hair
every day because i feel like i have to
keep up with the kardashians right but
i'm not sure how much it really matters
because in all of my experiences
with men i know
men cannot tell if a woman has good hair
they don't know
i've never seen guys at a bar pointing
at a girl like
[Music]
did you see that girl brian's talking to
her hair has like no volume
[Music]
[Applause]
should have seen the hair on the girl i
was with last night
[Music]
women we are way too insecure for no
reason uh i do not mean that in the body
positivity way uh because the body
positivity they make it those people
everything worse right do you remember
the dove soap normal bodies campaign
right
the women in the ads were like
we're bodies normal in our underwear by
our soap right
okay okay cool cool how is that supposed
to make anyone feel any better
right
saying your body is normal is not a
compliment
[Laughter]
the john mayer song was like your body
is normal
normal body no
don't think it would have been as big of
a hit right
my husband told me i looked normal once
i cried so hard my fake eyelashes fell
off
and you might have heard about that
because i did post about on facebook
nobody invited me to their parties that
week
all right thank you guys bye
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else